I have been to the Atacama Desert six times
already.
We are far from anywhere.
There's no bathroom, there is nothing.
You don't wash for five days.
Comparing what we do to a human mission on
Mars, what we do is very easy.
The Atacama Desert in Chile is one of the
driest and most surreal places on Earth, and
it is so unique that it may even hold answers
to questions about where we might find life
elsewhere in the universe.
The Atacama Desert is very similar to some
of the conditions we can find on Mars in terms
of salt chemistry, in particular.
Exposure to UV is much, much higher on Mars
than the Atacama Desert.
But this is as close as we can get.
It’s here that Dr. Jocelyne DiRuggiero studies
extremophiles, which are microorganisms that
live in extreme environments.
In this instance, she’s studying photosynthesizing
extremophiles that live inside of rocks, a
place that you wouldn’t expect light to
be able to penetrate.
We are interested in cyanobacteria, and they
are found everywhere on Earth.
They are primary producers, very much like
plants, so they use energy from the sun, carbon
dioxide, and water, and then they make organic
carbon, which is then used by other microorganisms.
They live inside rocks because they're protected
from high solar radiation, desiccation, but
it's also a place where water is retained
better than in the soil.
We're trying to find out how do they not only
survive, but thrive how do they grow, and
how do they evolve in those crazy conditions?
Jocelyne and her team used geological hammers
while collecting and opening rocks in the
desert, as well as several other tools to
measure weather, temperature, and humidity.
They also used a drill, spectrophotometer,
and fiber-optic sensor that measures the intensity
and color of any light penetrating the rock.
We pretended we were those little microorganisms
inside the rocks and what do we see?
What do we feel when we're out there in this
rock?
We had done experiments in the lab on other
types of rocks and we could see that the deeper
in the rock, the less light we had.
It looks like the light they see is a little
redder than the light that is outside the
rock, and so this brings the questions, "What
are the adaptations to the photo systems that
allow them to capitalize on this red light?"
It was from the bed of a pickup truck in the
howling winds that the scientists had to pull
off these complicated experiments.
But it paid off with some striking results.
The light experiments were quite surprising.
With the halite, which are sodium chloride
rocks basically, there is a lot of light,
even underneath the rock.
This has to do with the composition of the
salt rock and also the fact that the light
is reflected on the ground and bouncing back.
So those microbial communities that are at
different spots inside the rocks will see
different type of lights, and we didn't know
that before.
The quality of the light that reaches the
cyanobacteria could indicate how these organisms
are photosynthesizing from the inside of a
rock, compared to other primary producers,
like plants.
In order to figure out this process, Jocelyne
and the team want to take a closer look at
the organism's genome, to see if there are
any genetic mutations that allow them to live
in these extreme environments.
Back to the lab, where we'll do the molecular analysis to figure out who is there, what the community is
and also count the number of cells and trying to correlate the light
inside the rocks with the microbial community at the molecular level.
But sequencing the genome of these microorganisms
is going to take a while.
Once these experiments are complete, Jocelyne
and her team hope their data will be useful
to other research missions, like studying
how life can adapt to climate change, or thrive
on another planet.
Mars is very dry, so I'm not saying there is life
at the surface of Mars right now.
But you can imagine that Mars became more and more drier over its history.
It's very similar to what's happening in the Atacama Desert right now. It's getting drier and drier.
And so where are the last places where  we could find life on Mars, and can we find biosignatures of this life?
Sometimes it's challenging.
But at the same time, it’s very rewarding.
After you work really hard and you're really
tired, you sit around the campfire, we drink
a little scotch, brainstorm with ideas.
The skies at night in the Atacama are amazing.
You can see the whole Milky Way.
It's just totally mind-blowing.
This is really the time where you can get
new insight about what we do, and we also
talk about why we're doing this, why are we
scientists, what is our passion and this is
it.
For more episodes of Science in the Extremes,
check out this one right here.
Don’t forget to subscribe and come back
to Seeker for more episodes.
Thanks for watching.